[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
medio de todo lo que está ocurriendo en
ucrania existe un terreno que se ha
dejado de lado y es el de los
ciberataques que ha sufrido
recientemente este país y que para
muchos expertos pueden ser considerados
como un cuarto campo de batalla en
ningún caso se ha confirmado que estos
ataques vengan desde el kremlin sin
embargo hay indicios de que iniciaron en
rusia o en compañías aliadas rusas
existen tres tipos de ataques
documentados el primero es el de the
west o ataque de denegación de servicio
distribuido todos los sitios web tienen
una capacidad determinada para funcionar
con un número de usuarios o cantidad de
información en línea con esta técnica
las páginas web se llenan con
información basura de usuarios falsos
por lo que cuando un usuario real quiere
entrar se le deniega el acceso esto fue
lo que ocurrió un día antes de la
invasión con los sitios virtuales del
parlamento el gobierno el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores y otras instituciones
estatales ucraniano a su vez al día
siguiente algunos sitios rusos sufrieron
los mismos ataques
están destinados a denegar o degradar el
acceso de un servidor web o algún otro
sistema por lo tanto se puede usar
básicamente para saturar el tráfico de
un entorno de destino para que la
solicitud de legítima no puedan pasar
guillerme rojas quien gates ryu también
llenan el sitio de información para
realizar el servicio ya sea un servidor
web u otra cosa
la web se realizará una serie de
solicitudes que consumirán uno o muchos
recursos en ese sistema lugar resources
and access los expertos señalan que este
tipo de ataque más allá de ser
disruptivo no se considera realmente
peligroso por el contrario el segundo
fue algo que según las firmas de
seguridad cibernética schayman tec y el
set se registró un día antes pero hay
información de acciones similares desde
julio de 2021 se trata de un ataque con
correos de phishing con los que los
responsables roban información
confidencial de las personas y en estos
correos también pueden enviar lo que
sería la tercera forma de ataque y es la
instalación de un malware de limpieza
programa malicioso en este caso llamado
hermético hiper que puede bloquear o
borrar por completo los datos
almacenados en los equipos donde se
instala incluso puede permitir el
control remoto de esos equipos para
sustraer toda la información o realizar
diversas operaciones
consta de malware que generalmente causa
problemas físicos en un escritorio
sobreescribir algunos de los datos sobre
escribir algunas de las cosas que están
relacionadas con el sistema operativo y
que efectivamente interrumpir en ese
sistema y hacen el ataque a escalas
entonces dañan el entorno de destino
se puede comenzar con un ataque de
phising o con una cuenta comprometida o
un sistema vulnerable o mal configurado
y una vez que ingresan obtienen ese
punto de apoyo inicial y lo que hacen a
partir de ahí es que se mueven a otros
sistemas y en última instancia
servidores donde pueden obtener
credenciales y el acceso que necesitan
acceder and shows access the meal
cambiamos ahora o de tema y vamos hasta
jordania porque un grupo de arqueólogos
jordanos y franceses halló restos de un
de unos 9.000 años de antigüedad en el
desierto oriental de esa nación
es un descubrimiento extraordinario
totalmente nuevo
descubrimos un sitio de rituales
compuesto por varios elementos están
listos dos piedras verticales con
representaciones antropomórficas
asociadas a depósitos rituales de más de
250 artefactos
mis piezas arqueológicos y entre estas
piezas había muchos fósiles marinos eso
es bastante inusual en un contexto
arqueológico como éste
las estructuras datan aproximadamente
del año 7000 antes de cristo y consisten
en muros de piedra de varios kilómetros
de largo que se extienden hasta unirse
se cree que el objetivo de esas
estructuras era acorralar a las gacelas
en un área pequeña facilitando su
captura este tipo de instalación es
común en oriente medio y en el suroeste
de asia no obstante los expertos indican
que ésta sería la más antigua y la mejor
conservada hasta
y el sitio es único primero por su
estado de conservación tiene 9000 años y
todo estaba casi intacto las piedras
verticales los fósiles también fueron
depositados y colocados en un diseño
específico
encontramos que había una economía de
producción no era simplemente cacería
para su propio consumo para el grupo era
una economía de producción y de
intercambio
entre los más de 250 objetos hallados en
el yacimiento se incluyen dos estatuas
de piedra con rostros humanos tallados y
figurillas de animales que se cree que
eran utilizadas en rituales para invocar
a fuerzas sobrenaturales y obtener el
éxito en la cacería
y finalizamos en mexico donde fueron
diseñados y construidos 5 pequeños
robots que serán enviados a la luna como
parte de la misión colmena para
demostrar si es factible construir
estructuras una vez que ya se está sobre
la superficie de este satélite los
robots están programados para trabajar
como una especie de enjambre
entonces hacer pequeños robots pero
hacer muchos eventualmente muchísimos o
sea esto es una pequeña emisión en la
cual vamos a probar el concepto pero los
podemos hacer otras misiones a la luna
primero asteroides después donde lo que
vamos a ir es expandir este concepto y
volverlo útil si quieren una herramienta
que pueda hacer algo recoger minerales
explorar etcétera están equipados con
computadoras sensores de corriente
voltaje y proximidad además tienen la
capacidad de resistir temperaturas
extremas y trabajarán como un centro de
medición independiente enviando datos a
nuestro planeta se estima que la misión
tendrá una duración de 13 días así
finalizamos este espacio les agradecemos
su sintonía y los invitamos a continuar
con nosotros en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
a